game number two of this three-game
series st louis and san diego first
post-season start for zach davies two on
two out
for yadier molina now yada ya who's the
kind of guy that might hit this fella
and in the first inning yadier molina
delivers one down the line edmond will
score
dylan carlson on his way to third and
the cardinals jump on davies with a very
patient approach here in the first
inning zach davies facing matt carpenter
to start the st louis
second carpenter with a lot of at bats
against davies
and carpenter yanks one to right his
success against davies continues it'll
get all the way into the corner will
myers finds it and carpenters standing
up at second base with a lead off double
you talked about how much success that
zach davies has had down in the zone
carpenter just that hold it back looking
for something up got a change up that
was elevated until it got to the wall
down that right field line so now it is
uh
harrison bader and he has a chance to
add to the cardinal lead which is one to
nothing lead off doubled by carpenter
he's at second base with one away and
here's the pitch to uh
vader and it's up the middle and that's
a base hit and the cardinals uh lead uh
if he can score and the throw comes home
and he is safe at home and it is two
nothing and down the second base
is
mr uh bader so uh vader comes through
and the car doesn't lead to nothing and
now
uh the cardinal leadoff man could add to
that here's a fastball and a fly ball
deep in the right field if it's fair
it's a home run and it is a home run and
the cardinals get two more wow this is
really something the cardinals are on
the board with three runs here in the
second inning and they now lead
four nothing fifth career postseason
home run as colton wong unloaded on that
unlike any ball he'd hit all season the
runners lead at first and second
fernando tatis jr wearing number 23 on
the home white pinstripe uniform for the
padres here's a pitch up and and foul
tip yachty hands on the ball hit the bat
and yachty caught it strike three on
tati's yachty somehow caught the ball he
was following it all the way in
big a bat for machado with two on and
two out wainwright's pitch
fastball strike three looking and the
two superstars for san diego leave two
on the padres have loaded the bases with
nobody out myers is really the only guy
in the padres that stands out
offensively against breaking balls he
might be a guy that could get underneath
one of those curveballs
and he pulls it down the line flagged
down by edmond a third for one
a little late to get to first the padres
get a run across but only run only one
excuse me the versatile edmond kept that
one from being an extra base hit for
myers and the padres have the bases
loaded again that'll do it for
wainwright the 39 year old will exit
with the bases loaded left-hander austin
gomber on to face jake cronenworth with
the bases loaded
and one out here's the 3-2 pitch it's
outside ball four and the padres get a
second run here in the inning jake
gronino a rookie not expanding
and after falling behind oh and two he
draws a bases loaded walk and it's four
to two cardinals here in the fourth
and this game can change with fernando
tatis junior and he's got the bases
loaded
swing and a miss at the fastball again
back-to-back strikeouts from gomber and
despite the bases loaded walk it's
another huge missed opportunity for san
diego
runners at first and second no one out
and it's a switch hitting a fowler at
the dish now
swinging a fly ball deep down the right
side and it is trouble big time it takes
one hop off the wall into the corner
that will score uh young and
the other man stops at third base so the
cardinals get it back fowler does the
job with an rbi double nice going uh mr
dexter fowler that's a big big base hit
now in the score easily was uh de young
and stopping at third base now because
the cardinals have runners it's a second
and third and there's still no one out
second and third one out he needs to get
that ball out of the infield he uh
brings it home and uh the cardinal
left-handed better puts it in play and
it's a roller down the first base line
he's out at the first base but the run
scores and the cardinals now lead to six
to two padres today two for 12 with
runners in scoring position fernando
tatis is one for three the 2-2
fernando a high-fly ball to deep left
hill car rushed for going long for el
nino
won't be his last playoff appearance
won't be his last playoff home run now
we got a ball game right here a one run
lead for the st louis cardinals here
come them boys and now machado
and that one's launched to left field
they go back to back
padres have tied it with tatis and
machado
and two guys that have followed each
other all season
have now powered the padres back into
this game the right-hander daniel ponce
de leon comes on to face myers then you
punch de leon
and this one is yank deep to left
towards the pole off the bricks in
another home run for san diego padres
have their first lead of the series the
third home run in the last two winnings
seven to six san diego here's
[Applause]
he's going to lead sportscenter he's
done it again another home run and the
padres add to their advantage an
opposite field shot that he knew from
the get-go and a fat flip the padres go
up nine to six and it's a one-run game
jerks and profile on first base two outs
here's the 2-1 myers swing stings it out
to deep center field bader's going back
bader's at the wall bader leaps gonna go
he did it again tati says too myers has
two what a night and what a shot by will
myers and it is 11 to eight san diego
two hits in this series for paul
goldschmidt both of them for extra bases
and he yanks that one deep to left field
it's gone in a hurry
second home run this series for paul
goldschmidt and the cardinals still have
life now dexter fowler with two on and
two out in the night
rips it to first handle by hosmer he'll
take it to the bag and we'll get a game
three
padres are alive they continue to chase
the big cake as they say